hi what's up my name is Samuel Leeds and
in this video I wanted to explain how
you can invest in UK property investment
so firstly before I tell you how and
what steps you should take a masseuse
plane why I personally love buying your
property investment in the UK and that
is because if I invest my money in
anything else I can invest it in the
bank if you put money in the bank the
money shrinks over time because as cost
of living goes up the money stays the
same the money becomes worth less over
time I can invest it in business and
that's great and that could be really
successful but of course there's always
a risk because the business could go
bust the stuff got staff that there's a
much higher risk I could put the money
in stocks and shares and again same sort
of problem it could disappear overnight
I can put the money in gold and someone
could steal the gold whereas if I put it
in property the property is attached
onto the land it's attached onto the
ground and it's gonna go up over time in
value because history repeats itself I'm
gonna get paid in capital appreciation
as the property appreciates in value and
I'm gonna have a tenant in there looking
after it paying me money as well so I
wanna get paid twice so that's why I
really wanna invest in property but the
question is how well there's different
ways to invest in property by the way if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
smash that like it hit the subscribe
button right now there's two different
ways basic ways number one is I can buy
and sell that's how most people think
about property investment they think
I'll buy a house or do it up and then
I'll sell it that's a fantastic method
however I prefer to buy and hold and the
reason I prefer to buy and hold is
because if you buy and sell effectively
you're still trading your time for money
because you're gonna have to buy it
you're gonna have to oversee it you have
to make sure that you can add value then
you're going to sell it and then you're
gonna get paid a good chunk of money so
you've got that money in exchange for
your time
so you're exchanging your time for money
which is fine but I think that the first
thing before you start doing that you
want to become financially free so you
want to be in a position whereby your
passive income covers your lifestyle so
that you don't have to work and you're
financially frightened to do that you're
going to need your rental income to
cover your living expenses yourself so
your properties have enabled you to go
full time in property and
and work because you want to not because
you have to so my properties most of
them I never ever ever ever plan on
selling them my plan is to hold on to
them until the day I die and I will just
benefit from the rents if they go up in
value rather than selling them
I'd rather refinance them and get a new
mortgage and then buy more properties
and then make more rent so I'm going to
be talking more about that strategy
which is buying and holding which we
call buy-to-let
so if you're wanting to get into the buy
to that market you are gonna typically
conventionally you're gonna need some
money behind you now I do teach in some
of my other videos how you can buy
property with no money so you can find
those on this channel
so typically we need to invite you that
you're going to put in twenty five
percent of the purchase price so I'm
going to use my calculator here to make
sure that these numbers are correct so
let's say you're buying a house for a
hundred thousand pounds you're going to
put in twenty five percent which means
you're gonna have to put in twenty five
thousand pounds to abide to that
property which is a hundred thousand
pound house now if you put twenty five
thousand pounds in that means your
mortgage is going to be seventy five
percent which is seventy five thousand
pounds now interest payments are
typically around about four buy to let
mortgages about three percent so you're
going to bring your interest payments of
three percent which is two thousand two
hundred and fifty pounds divide that by
twelve your monthly mortgage interest
payments are going to be one eight seven
so when you're looking at buying to that
property what you need to be looking at
is will your rent cover this one eighty
seven and more because your of course
you're going to have some costs
management costs maybe some maintenance
as the property goes on you might have
to change the carpets over a couple of
years maybe so you're gonna have to make
sure that your rent is a lot more than
one eighty seven to be making a profit
now the real trick is to buy low rent
high so that you can get a good return
now how do you even start what's the
very first thing that you should do
right now if you're interested in
investing in property but what I would
say is get yourself open the computer go
to Zoopla right move right move is the
best because there's so many hundreds of
thousands probably
move go to the right move look at the
properties available to learn find some
properties that and again most people
say I want to buy properties that are
nice I want to buy properties that I'd
live in myself no this is a business you
wanna buy properties that are gonna give
you a good return on investment that
you're gonna be able to buy low and rent
out high and people say I'll buy low
rent high that sounds like you're just a
greedy that horrible landlord No you'll
rent it out high because the property
would demand the high rent because
you're giving value and you'll buy it
low because you'll be buying it in an
area where buy right now houses you can
buy them reasonably large so this isn't
a case of trying to squeeze as much out
of the tenant as possible you're gonna
have to look after the tenant let me
tell you this property investing is of
business your house is your product you
want a good product your tenant is your
customer this is a business about supply
and demand so you're going to try and
find the correct on a house it's going
to give you a very good return on
investment what I would suggest go right
now find some houses that you think
could give you a good return on
investment ringing up the agent and ask
to go and look around the house the best
way to learn this is to actually just go
out and look around the house if you
want to learn all about watches you know
understand about watches you're probably
best to just go to a shopping mall and
look at watches and try them on and get
an understanding if you wanna learn
about sports cars go and do some test
drives learn about cars go and see some
cars if you want to learn about property
what I would say is just go and view
some houses don't feel like all but I'm
not quite ready to buy a house no no
just go and do some houses go and speak
to this data just tell them what you
want say look I'm thinking of I'm
interested in investing in property can
you give them can you give me some good
investment properties you'll learn so
much of them when they show you around
make sure that you're looking at
properties not with your feelings but
with your formulas I've done a video
which is how to work out the return on
investment I check that out just above
you know look at properties they're
going to give you the best return on
investment now what are the risks to
buying property what are the things you
need to be careful of I think the risks
are one buying a bad house a blind a
house that needs too much work that
you're unaware of
this can often happen by but if you buy
from an auction or if you buy really
hastily based on feelings so again when
you buy a house always get a survey I
recommending an independent
Builders survey to look at it with a
fine-tooth comb to check any problems
and then quotes how much it's gonna cost
to fix those next not just a bad house
but also you've paid the wrong price for
the house so again always make sure that
if you're getting a mortgage on it it's
not too bad because the lender will not
lend to you on the property unless it is
worth the amount that you're paying for
it if you're paying over the odds it
will get down valued make sure you don't
pay over the odds of the house
someone once said if you're not
embarrassed about the offer that you put
forward then the offer is too high so
always go in a little bit lower the
worst of happen is they can say no and
then you can creep off a little bit once
you've bought the house what are the
risks then bad tenants
no tenants I always say everything will
went out at the right price you just
need to know what the right price is so
make sure you do your due diligence you
get trained you speak to these state
agents you speak to the local election
agents and you know how much the house
will rent out for who the types of
tenants will be and next make sure that
you've got a good property management
company that are going to do references
they're getting to all the credit checks
they're gonna make sure they're putting
the right tenants in to your property so
if you've got the right power seen have
the right surveys the right property
managers you do you write due diligence
property investing I think is one of the
most lucrative ways to make money and I
also think it's the best place to invest
your money if you look at the rich list
nearly all of the people on the rich
list either have made their money
through property or they have made their
money through business or whatever and
now they are also investing in property
but probably is always defend so I love
property through throat I think the UK
is one of the best places to invest in
property - despite some of the
uncertainty that's going on right now
when people are a little bit uncertain
that's when you need to be super greedy
and get in there as Warren Buffett would
say so I hope that video is kind of
giving you some ideas and being helpful
I'd love to know your thoughts so please
do comment below and do not forget to
subscribe stay tuned and I look forward
to seeing you next time thank you so
much for watching this video it's
mentoring on a Monday every single week
at 7 p.m. on a Monday between 8 p.m. I'm
gonna be live answering all your
comments and questions don't forget to
subscribe right over here so you'll
never miss one of these videos I'll see
you next week at 7 p.m.
also if you haven't got a copy of my
book you need there
in your life you can get it from Amazon
for ten pound 99 or a gift from made
absolutely free down below in the
description link I'll see you next week
Monday at 7 p.m.